el ministro de Justicia francesa que por
ahora no está en la orden del día una
posible renuncia su cargo ni siquiera
después de que ayer la corte de justicia
de la República lo enviara nuevamente
frente a los tribunales en un caso por
conflicto de intereses de su época
cuando era abogado sus acusadores dicen
que
ha utilizado su cargo como ministro para
ajustar cuentas con jueces que lo
habrían perjudicado en su época como
jurista él dice que cuenta con la
confianza de la primera ministra algo
que confirmó el gabinete de Elizabeth
born Y además que es un justiciable como
cualquier otro que sí debe ir a los
tribunales lo hará y contará su versión
sin embargo esta polémica ha opacado la
idea de República ejemplar que quería
crear Emmanuel macron sobre todo después
de que ayer se supiera que el secretario
general del palacio del inicio
alexiquela también está haciendo
encausado en una investigación por
conflicto de intereses en su caso Keller
que además fue el jefe de gabinete de
Manuel macron cuando era ministro de
economía está siendo investigado por los
vínculos que tiene con una empresa
armadora suizo italiana que es propiedad
de la familia de su madre esta empresa
era cliente de un armador francés que es
una empresa pública y de cuyo directorio
formaba parte del éxito cuando Él
trabajaba en el Ministerio de economía
francés